loud finally did it after battling with
optic off and on all year they managed
to close out the 2022 season by winning
the big one champions was easily the
most hyped tournament of the vct season
there were insane comebacks controversy
curses were broken and the grand final
was the most watched match in the game's
young history so in case you're living
under a rock or maybe you're a cs stan
or maybe both here's what you missed
before we get into the video i just want
to remind you guys about our new merch
that's available for purchase at
shop.thescore.com there's a lot of cool
stuff there including this dope crewneck
that i'm wearing right now
so make sure to check it out all right
so the 2022 valerian season is
officially over and it was definitely
one for the books throughout the year we
saw each region prove that the
international competition is closer than
ever before na and emea took home both
masters events and every other region
showed that they can compete at the
highest level and champions was no
different aside from paper rex making an
early exit in the group stage i think
you could say that the first week of the
event went pretty much how everyone
would have expected i was sad to see my
boys from zeta division go home early
but the playoffs definitely didn't
disappoint loud dominated the upper
bracket making their way to the grand
final without dropping a single map and
although drx looked destined to finish
the tournament in fifth or sixth like
they always do they managed to prove us
all wrong alfier holding it stacks on
the swing alfier falls but it's still a
1v1
can mystic do it
87 hp the flash is off topic no
the red bull clutch for drx and the face
of history they write a new future they
advance
on the other side of the lower bracket
fpx's win over xset was overshadowed by
a bug which we covered at the time
exit's post plant including setting up a
killjoy turret for those of you who
don't know killjoy's turret swings and
shoots someone when it comes into its
field of vision but sometimes if the
line of sight is broken it will freak
out and just shoot somewhere else so in
this case the turret correctly saw angel
door but with angel moving it had a
little freak out and shoots heaven in
this case def continues to hold heaven
most likely because he has been given
information by the turret that someone
is there waiting that information was
incorrect and def had a 1v2 after aaron
and zekin were picked off which he did
not win the controversial decision was
made to replay the round but
unfortunately riot didn't exactly
communicate to the players that this was
solely their decision so fbx were
understandably a little bit heated after
beating axette for a second time despite
this i think that exxon had a great
showing they proved that they're among
the world's best and came extremely
close to securing a top 4 finish even
though it was a bitter end to their
tournament they should be proud in the
following round fpx fell to drx in an
insane series that ended with the
koreans coming back from a 9-3 deficit
to secure a top 3 finish if you're a fan
of korean valorant then i'm sure you're
pretty happy with drx this is the best
showing we've seen from a korean roster
since neutron finished third in iceland
last year but next i have to talk about
yeah
you've got to play this a little bit
aggressively
but there it is that's all you needed he
plays ahead of the timing finds
leicester there's a player close by and
he's still doing this he has to be the
protagonist in this room
what's that completely unaware and yay
this three could be on for the ace if he
gets the timing right he knows he reads
it like a book yay it's an animal in
these moments
just one more and it looks so good with
yay doing this of course that's the way
this half closes out with yay picking up
an ace yay was on a heater all
tournament long he proved that he's the
best player in the entire world and his
performance was a huge reason why optic
were able to represent na in their third
international grand finals but even
though yay was playing lights out in the
end it just wasn't enough optic met loud
in the grand finals for what felt like
the millionth time this year but this
time the brazilians got their revenge
and show that they truly are the super
team that was promised from the start of
the year none of us were to the start of
this round that's best float good four
oh my god for two and now just the 1v1
and the correct guess victor none the
wiser forced to pull the trigger
the unthinkable again the 1v3 in the
final seconds
and he's gone back for more he's gone
that's despite now seeing as well so
telling at this time the rest of the
team is on the way through caves are
just so well punishing oh
can you believe it as fast the heads
crashes and sassy now in the 1v2 blonde
gonna come in but they are closing the
gap faster safe plan for the nellis
players along
did he knows the one closer garage he
absolutely has and with 40 hp
he's done the unthinkable he's taking
them to 12. it's all on one the last man
standing at finesse and after so much
time so many years of heartbreak at the
hands of optic loud beat them in the
best possible way
becoming the ballerina 2022 champion
what a moment i'm extremely happy for
loud after getting grouped in copenhagen
a lot of people were doubting them but
this time around they proved all their
haters wrong and with the first
tournament of the 2023 season set to
take place in sao paulo i'm sure they'll
get a very warm welcome from their fans
but at the time of writing this there's
a lot going on in the ballarat scene
just yesterday we got news that after
the recent controversy surrounding their
owner carlos g2 are likely out after
riot held an emergency meeting to decide
their fate and today riot announced all
30 teams who made it into their
partnership program aside from the
absence of optic tsm nip and the guard
the americas league has pretty much
shaped up as expected over in emea i was
a little surprised to see this many
spanish orgs make it in and ascend and
guild were the most notable omissions
lastly we have the pacific region zeta
and paper rex made it in as expected and
many of the big korean orgs who have
been part of the lck for years are
included t1 is an interesting one though
because as of right now they have two
english-speaking players on their roster
i'm also surprised that there are no oce
representatives but i'm glad that global
esports is here because i know the
indian valorant scene is very passionate
about the game but some of the best
teams from around the world don't even
have a spot so i'm certain that we'll
see a hell of a lot of roster moves in
the coming weeks with partnered teams
bolstering their rosters with proven
talent some players and teams will
likely be representing new orgs next
year and although there's a lot to be
excited about for the future of valorent
i can't help but feel sorry for those
who end up on the outside looking at
um
i think i think this tournament kind of
just showed that
like every region really can compete drx
broke their curse um
emea can still compete but uh sao paulo
is gonna be sick i'm excited for sao
paulo like i wanna go man i wanna go so
bad i hope we can go